[Music]
over the years vice presidential
candidates have at times stolen the
spotlight senator you're no Jack Kennedy
with all due respect that's a bunch of
malarkey historically though the
selection of a running mate rarely
proves decisive Who am I why am I here
this time it's different divisions in
the Democratic Party new battleground
states and Joe Biden's age make the
presumptive nominees pick one of the
most important in modern times he has
started much earlier to make his choice
than people normally do he has said
something nobody has ever said before
which is a commit that I will in fact
pick a woman to be vice president and
he's made a very public show of picking
a group of people who will help him make
the choice so who was the former vice
president going to pick to fill the role
there was an emerging short list of
candidates including senators Kamala
Harris of California Amy Klobuchar of
Minnesota Elizabeth Warren of
Massachusetts and Katherine Cortes Masto
of Nevada then there is governor
Gretchen Whitmer of Michigan and former
Georgia legislator Stacey Abrams how
Biden will Peck however remains unclear
but history might provide some help my
name is Geraldine Ferraro I believe
you're looking at the next vice
president of the United States
traditionally a nominee selects a
running mate for one of three reasons
the first balance basically using the
pick to make up for a perceived weakness
or bring in more voters so an
interesting case study in balance was
1980 when Ronald Reagan was the
Republican nominee and he tried to bring
some balance by bringing in somebody who
had more experience than he did at the
federal national Washington level
because at the beginning of the
convention in 1980 there was a serious
movement afoot to put Gerald Ford a
former president on the ticket as Ronald
Reagan's vice presidential running mate
they moved on to the other kind of
balance which was ideological balance
Ronald Reagan a real conservative needed
to reassure moderates in the Republican
Party that he hadn't gone too far right
so his ultimate choice was George HW
Bush who is the personification of the
moderate wing of the Republican Party in
2008 Republican nominee John McCain
considered an unprecedented kind of
balance taking Democrat Joe Lieberman
there was an important statement wrapped
up in this idea of wanting to pick Joe
Lieberman and that statement was I'm not
going to govern as a traditional
partisan president I'm going to be a
president for all the people of course
that idea was dropped I will be honored
to accept your nomination for Vice Biden
has promised gender balance but his pick
could bring balance of another kind
Elizabeth Warren is the one person on
Joe Biden's short list who would provide
ideological balance she would reassure
the Bernie Sanders wing of the party
that their issues and their concerns and
and their approach would be reflected in
a Biden administration the other kind of
balance is basically racial balance
there's a lot of pressure on him to pick
somebody a candidate of color who can
basically represent that part of the
party that was so instrumental in his
winning the nomination and Kamala Harris
from California obviously does that as
well for Joe Biden another reason
presidential candidates picked bp's
geography you can always see one or two
states that could tip the balance and if
you can pick a running-mate
who guarantees you or virtually
guarantees you'll win one of those key
states well that's a pretty powerful
incentive the nomination of the
Democratic Party when John Kennedy was
running in 1960 he picks Lyndon Johnson
of Texas to be his running mate Texas
was an important state for Democratic
presidential aspirations in those days
and I am grateful finally that I can
rely on the coming months won a
distinguished running mate who brings
unity and strength to our platform in
our ticket Lyndon Johnson Kennedy and
Johnson went on to win tax
since the start of the modern two-party
era in 1892 the winner has carried the
running mates home state 87% of the time
that means just six winning tickets in
the last 192 years were able to win
without carrying the vice presidential
nominees home state if you were picking
one region of the country that's going
to be essential for Joe Biden to win to
win the presidency it would probably be
the industrial Upper Midwest and so
therefore Gretchen Whitmer the governor
of Michigan becomes a very intriguing
figure here Amy Klobuchar has a similar
appeal across the Upper Midwest because
she's from Minnesota she also seems to
have an ability to speak to voters in
places like Michigan and Wisconsin as
well the final reason candidates pick a
running-mate to reassure voters that
someone experienced will be able to step
in as president at a moment's notice in
the event of the president's death
taking over is one of the vice
president's only stated jobs and it's
something voters think about now I think
it's the whole ballgame for Joe Biden
because let's face it he's going to be
77 on election day he will be 78 when he
sworn in if he wins the election in
other words he would be as old coming
into the presidency as Ronald Reagan was
when he exited the presidency given
Biden's age it's also possible he may
decide to only serve a single term if
elected that could make his pick the
frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination next time around so who's
ready now I think the senators who are
on the Biden short list become
intriguing because they presumably know
how the government works in Washington
now had worked the levers of power
versus a governor who has executive
experience but not Washington experience
a number of politicians on Biden short
lists have said they would accept the
nomination if asked whoever Biden
selects however faces another unique
challenge former Senate staffer Tara
Reed accused Biden of sexual assault
Biden has denied the claim but the woman
he picks as his running mate will likely
also battle questions about the
allegation some of his top choices
already have and I agree with Vice
President Biden about this that all
women in these cases have the right to
be hurt and have their claims thoroughly
reviewed I
no Joe Biden and I think that he is
telling the truth and that this did not
happen you know the Joe Biden I know
this is somebody who really has fought
for women and environment of women and
for women's equality and mates but his
advisory panel now in place Biden said
his selection could come as early as
July
you